so I got to believe and um
the chorus was great but the verse was
terrible and so my producer who I never
had a crossword with kept saying you
have to sing it better you have to sing
it better and if I said babe if you
wanted something better get somebody
else so then he I left and then he said
I the next day he said you know I've
been playing around with the pitch
machine and I think I might have
something so I went in and I sat next to
him and he started to play it and it was
unbelievable because it was never
anything like it and when it was done we
high-fived each other and then the
people from the record company who I
loved and the Germans I don't know why
they were in there but anyway they were
oh I can't say this but um so they said
well you can't no you we don't know it's
you and I went exactly exactly from the
beginning in the beginning and it spiced
up the verse and it was just it just
sailed you know and then they said you
you can't have it and I said well can
you believe this yeah okay it's my show
we can do whatever you want so anyway I
said okay you can take it out Over My
Dead Body
[Applause]
how many of you used to do the Jane
Fonda workout videos
[Applause]
did it with Jane Fonda so did Sally
I did it with my mom
[Applause]
I actually used to her first um workout
place was in the valley and I used to go
that because I lived in the valley and
one day there she was teaching the class
it was like jaw dropping and I was like
working out right behind her I luckily
was in the business then but just a very
tiny aspect of the business because I
was doing television and she was already
I attended her class too
wow do you remember that do you remember
me no you don't
I remember Sally I don't remember you
that is real friendship
come back
she'll make it up to you
there we go here we go
I remember you we all remember you they
don't remember his hands you are
memorable
just not for her Jane huh it's too late
[Applause]
um is it true that you wrote a secret
song that nobody else has ever heard and
you put it in a time capsule yes and
that has drove me crazy because people
bring it up no yeah because they bring
it up but because I have written a song
that nobody's going to hear till I'm 99
years old and I might be there I might
not be but it's when uh we did Dollywood
when we worked that yeah and we put it
in a time capsule to be you know to be
um open kind of honor the whole company
yeah and so uh and I put all the things
that had to do with the times I put a
cassette player and I put a uh all the
CD player I put stuff all in this box
that if if it would preserve it to what
how we played those you know at the time
but I put that in the box but I had to
write this song that nobody was going to
hear till then and I tell you have no
idea how that has bothered me I want to
go dig that up so bad and think well I
need to use that song because he's like
you know and it's a really good song but
yes I I have a song that's buried that
nobody's going to hear till I don't know
whose damn idea that was yeah yeah cut
off is there a date do you know we need
to find the date when we get to unearth
it so I'm 76 and it's when I'm 99 years
old it is when you're 99 yeah I'd be 99
years old when they when they open it
yeah you got like a lot more time to
wait for that I know but they weren't
expecting me to be there at all and well
that's just probably won't be that's
just rude but I mean I'm just saying I
might be there who knows but the point
is there is a song I figure that
probably disintegrate probably nobody
ever heard that's what bothers me to
think that it's going to be a song that
nobody ever going to hear if it rots in
there before before the beautiful thing
though when they open it what a what a
beautiful thing I love I'm totally and
I've done Time Capsule gifts before more
as a joke like I gave Blake Shelton a
time capsule for his birthday last year
to open it the one this year and it was
just like my team Kelly jacket from The
Voice
and I was because he kept throwing it
away and I was like you've had this for
a year joke's on you
um so but anyway I've done it in a funny
way but I've never done it in a serious
way and I think that's the most
beautiful too for like people to do for
like their kids like make something for
their kids if you can't sing like make a
video and like have them unearth it at
some point think that's really special
well it'll be hopefully it'll be special
and you'll still be there
some of you might be someone you might
know but it is true though but it's not
fear and I have to honestly say it was
an odd feeling to be asked to write a
song that nobody was not going to hear I
mean it was not going to be heard that
is annoying yeah yeah but it's a good
song oh well we we don't know
yeah no you don't but I mean I felt like
it was a good song and I think oh I
don't know if this maybe I'll write a
bad song and put it in there who's gonna
remember me then yeah he should have
done it like a more of a joke like
joke's on you you thought this was gonna
be great that's right you should have
called it no that's what I'm going to do
now I'm going to go dig that up bury
that right beside it get the other one
we've got the legendary Carol burn out
with us
so let's finish things up here with
something Carol liked to do on her show
and her comedy specials which we love
which is take questions from the
audience all right let's turn to our
audience for their questions right now
so who has a question for Carol oh
everybody has a question for Carol all
right well I'm just do we want to pick
do I want to pick I get to pick I'm
gonna pick you right here in the blue
how about that
hi Carol hi in the 90 years that you've
been on this planet what would you say
is the most important thing you've
learned
oh that's a big question do you have
about 40 hours
not to take yourself too seriously not
to take yourself too seriously okay
check okay I'm gonna go with orange back
there yeah with the cool red hair come
on now
hi
outside of entertainment what do you
still want to accomplish in your life
oh outside of entertainment what do you
want to accomplish George Clooney
[Applause]
oh my God
it's my favorite part of this whole show
okay Angela this is you
what
oh violations of personal space yeah
yeah you know so like when I went in to
hug you is that okay no that's okay
that's okay but a lot of times people
will come up on me like real close oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and they're like oh we love you okay
yeah so I don't like you to run up on me
real close yeah that kind of thing or
grab me or something like that
unexpectedly because I'm not grabbing
you yeah because we don't know them but
like but here's the thing but also have
you ever been I think violation of
person space is when I go to the
restroom at a restaurant and someone
follows me in they have knocked on the
door I'm like I'm having a moment right
and I don't know what kind of moment it
is but I definitely don't want you to be
here for it like and then they'll slide
I've had someone slide a piece of paper
and like pen and I'm like do you want me
to sign
it feels wrong yeah I think that's a
violation you want to take a photo yeah
yeah you don't want that photo one of
the groups you wrote a lot for over the
years was Boys to Men
which I love
dude this is this is my first record I
ever bought Motown Philly it was my
first CD I ever people are like what's
the CD the younger generation but
whatever I'm older
um I I love this album and do you
remember the first time that you met
them I met them first time when I did
this song with them into the road
the first song because they they just
did they were really hot they did Motown
Philly and and so we wanted to do um
have them on the Boomerang soundtrack
yeah and so that was like the first
that's the song I wrote
um where I was trying to figure out what
kind of song to write for them because
you know they weren't doing that kind of
song exactly yet but they were from
Philly and they were and it just and
they said Philly Motown so I wanted to
give that old school kind of feel yeah
and um I love that you brought it back
to guitar like the acoustic thing well
that's actually
that was that ended up being later
because we went on the end of the road
we ended up doing that but we ended up
doing another song called water running
that's what I mean that's what I mean
water register I thought that's where
you're going yeah yeah because I love
how it starts out so that went back you
know to that sixth grade kid again yeah
once again maybe you should write a
thank you letter to this lady like like
I maybe we all should right now just get
out our pilot G2 pen and go to town like
like I'm just saying like that woman
helped us out tremendously with our own
relationships via your music it's funny
because years later I ended up you know
tracking her down
yeah
because I wanted to talk to her and see
if I remembered everything the same yeah
you know and it was pretty close and uh
what did she say yeah no I went into it
like yeah no just a real quick recap I
didn't want you like what did what did
that conversation go like she said that
she didn't
she ultimately said you know I I spend
most of my life always thinking about
people that hurt me I never think
thought about the people that I may have
heard along the way she was sorry write
that song sir exactly that's a great
lyric it was a great lyric yeah and I
said um I said to her don't apologize
it's because of you you launched the kid
that wrote a thousand songs yeah
[Applause]
I had them on the you know I call them
the week he announced before anybody
knew who he was provided him on The
Tonight Show you know and because
everybody thought Hillary had it in the
bag you know so he came in and you go
Jay my name's Brock was saying Obama I'm
uh running for president United States I
said okay well let's look at the odds
here black guy named Hussein from
Chicago
nobody ever heard of him ah you're gonna
win pal you're going to be a shoe-in you
know and you know he was very funny he
had a great time
so he and I became friends and he gave
he gave me a cell phone number so I said
so I would tell one day I'm telling my
friend now you know how this is when you
come to a small town you have the same
Idiot Friends your whole life that you
grew up with yeah so I'm telling my
friends you know I got Obama's cell
phone let's call him up and we're not
going to call them you go you don't have
it
but like 45 year old man were going on
okay so finally my friends no you don't
have it I said first of all it's
probably shut off since he's president
well if he shut off let's call it
I said what time it's three o'clock in
California it's 12 o'clock all right I
dial the number I hear Brock here oh Mr
President yeah it's Jay Leno what can I
do for you Jay uh should I throw this
number away good idea Jay
I was like you didn't have a plan I
didn't think he's gonna answer the phone
oh my God you have oh well I was just
calling about the crisis in and if you
needed any help like exactly oh my God
none of my friends care what I do they
don't care whose number I have I'm not
cool your friends still think you're
cool well no they don't really think I'm
cool but but you know it's pretty cool
to have brothers you have the same Idiot
Friends that you would like 100 yeah
yeah I mean I'm not calling them idiots
so shout out April Mary I'm calling mine
idiot well you're also when we um
referred to a minute ago at 1923 with
Harrison Ford so like this is
I love it
all of I love all the there's three
different ones you can watch right so I
love them all but I I love y'alls
because I just I I love
um one I love that your accent to the
whole thing and I love your backstory
and I love how it showed kind of a
different side to immigrants in America
that you don't normally see in shows
like this like in Wild West stuff like
even growing up you don't really see
that a lot I was always just white
people just like basic white well true
American play but in in reality you know
we shot in a place called Butte which is
in Montana I literally live an hour from
it I have a ranch in Montana so you know
you're huge yeah
it's a beautiful I live like an hour
like higher up in the mountains yeah
it's so beautiful Montana it's
incredible but beautiful has this
amazing history old mining town as
you've known and um you know when you
look at the history of Butte there were
people from Moldavia there they were
Welsh guys they were Scottish people
they were Irish people you know uh
people from The Basque region so that's
that's what the West was like all these
different accents and cultures but
that's what I love that y'all today yeah
yeah so that was very much why I wanted
to play her Irish yeah yeah it was very
very cool I'm like look I know that
there's like there's one store in Butte
and it's like Walmart so like I love
like James Helen has been debuted
that's where I go to get groceries
because where I live is like super
remote yeah so like that's where I drive
to get like milk yes I know that warm up
very well I joke like at the back of my
house me too but I just love that you've
walked the aisles
it's just out of like it's just out of
pocket for me I heard that you do magic
you know what I I have a masters in uh
in magicology so I
I do I do magic I I it's in my fingers
did you make up magicology no I made it
up okay
okay I feel like wait not only did I
make it up but I only do one trick okay
great
great yes you want to see it yes I do I
have the trick with me okay you have
this I tell you where I learned it
to learn it I will make that disagree I
I can do that too I have money to give
everybody yeah
okay
there you go I mean okay okay so what
are we doing is this part of the trick
this is not part of the trick at all you
get to go out and just have drinks
together okay all right it's buying us
drinks
and in L.A this shall buy one yeah so
it's that I'm here what do I have here
you have a quarter okay is that a
quarter that's a quarter all right now
listen very carefully okay
yeah is that a quarter that's a quarter
right that can't be my fingers no okay
here we go okay all right okay okay
magicology here we go
here we go
okay what no oh no okay now
okay count to three okay one two three
hell
[Applause]
I know that I've talked to you about
your album a lot I know you can keep
going I I probably think I'm psychotic
at this point literally every time I see
him at the show I'm like dude I was like
I can't and this is a testament it's one
of my favorite song oh my gosh I mean
um I love I love wild actually what
you're going to be performing today but
yes um favorite place
I really love I love the whole album
conversation in the dark I love the
whole thing it's so so cool those songs
are kind of sexy songs dude I know
that's what I'm saying this is a
testament of how good this album is I
started this show with saying like hey
my personal life is kind of like
and so I'm just saying if this album can
be so great for someone like me that's
really wanting some Joni Mitchell Alanis
Morissette at this point like it's a
great album well thank you I I truly you
know uh we all work in this business and
so we can be a little jaded and cynical
I know I'm never like this with albums
and for another artist to actually care
about your music and listen to it and
love it and really pay attention it
really does mean a lot so I am truly
grateful for your compliments and they
are not getting old to me okay I
appreciate it
falling down
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]